foreign
Russian media is reporting that an
unmanned drone has crashed in the Moscow
region the governor says the drawing was
targeting a facility used by civilians
they have been no casualties or property
damage but the incident is being
investigated by local authorities and
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
told his security service to step up its
activity to counter what he called
growing Espionage operations against
Russia
we must strengthen our
counterintelligence as Western special
services have always traditionally
worked against Russia in an active way
they have now thrown additional
Personnel Technical and other resources
against us we must respond to it
accordingly
and the Russian defense Ministry has
accused the U.S of planning a so-called
provocation in Ukraine using toxic
chemicals Osama bin Javid has more from
Moscow
the ministry of defense for the first
time has actually detailed a plan of how
uh allegedly chemical weapons have been
brought into Ukraine in near the
donyesque region this is where intense
fighting has been taking place for the
last few months the ministry of Defense
has actually identified the number of
Bogies the type of chemicals it says
could be used and which will be a
violation of the organization of the
prohibition of chemical weapons treaties
so it is all happening this morning in
Russia there seems to be a more alarm
bells ringing than actual fighting
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is warning that the situation
in the Eastern Frontline city of bakmuth
is getting worse Regional separatist
leaders say nearly all the roads into
the city are now under Russian control
the area has been the site of a bitter
deadly battle for more than six months
the situation is constantly becoming
more difficult the enemy is constantly
destroying everything that can be used
to protect our positions for
fortification and defense our soldiers
defending in the Bahamut region are real
heroes